welcome back to Facebook veganism the
art of issuing all pleasure in life is
one of the 21st Century's most bizarre
Trends from where I look at it but there
are green plant-based shoots of recovery
the new fashion is for high profile
beacons including Explorer Bay grills to
preventing the detransitioning back to
healthy meaty diets and so many chefs
like John Mountain who runs Fire
restaurant in Perth Australia is also
leading the fight back he's made Global
headlines this week after announcing
sadly all vegans are banned from fire
for mental health reasons we thank you
for your understanding many didn't
understand he's been flooded with fake
bookings and hostile reviews but I'm
joined now by the vegan Banner himself
John mountain and here in the studio
animal rights activist Joey carb strong
well welcome to both of you okay John
Mountain why did you ban vegans from
your restaurant
uh morning peers I banned them from my
restaurant because look I've been a chef
for nearly 30 years but on this
particular incidence it was just too
much you know they grouped together
which you know I'm very proud of the
vegans for all sticking together but
they did they grouped and banded
together and then started hammering my
business with one star reviews I saw my
rating dropped from a sensible 4.2 down
to 2.8 they they nearly broke me God
bless the vegans though what was the
incident that provoked all this
the problem that happened was a girl had
emailed me three weeks before uh
requesting a vegan selection and I said
well look rather than saying that what
is it that you like tell me what you
like and she said well
you know I like gnocchi and risotto I
thought okay no problem we changed our
menu every day peers so it's not an
issue the problem was on the day that
she did turn up I I couldn't do it I I
let her down and it was a justifiable
complaint
and she went nuts
yeah slightly nuts my thing about vegans
is they tend to be I don't know they
seem to be permanently hangry like the
lack of meat in their diet makes them
very intolerant of people and they get
very agitated and if you don't sign up
to all things vegan in the way that they
want you to all the Hell Breaks Loose
I think that seems to be the issue
um appears to be honest I think they're
just missing a really good burger or a
glass of milk you know or both uh you
know they need to sleep more be a bit
more healthy although you know the vegan
diet allegedly is healthy just not for
everybody else you know I think each to
their own is one of them okay let's come
to Joey it's a joey Bay Grill so I know
well so he's embarrassed to use to
promote veganism uh he now eats a diet
of red meat blood bone marrow as well as
salted butter eggs fruit and honey says
he's never felt better talking about his
transition to a vegan diet so I was
vegan quite a few years ago I thought I
wrote a vegan cookbook I now feel a bit
embarrassed about that because I
promoted I thought that was good for the
environment I thought it was good for my
health and through time and experience
and knowledge and study I realized I was
wrong on both
he's embarrassed to that he promoted a
plant-based diet when he drinks urine
and buy a lot of camel's stomach is
quite healthy it's healthy would you
drink urine would you rather drink urine
absolutely
he's embarrassed that he uh now that he
uh promoted a vegan diet and he's not
embarrassed of his behavior on TV and he
thinks that eating the bodies of them
why are vegans so angry
well um he he made a statement saying uh
the vegans are angry and angry but he
carried on and banned all vegans from
his restaurant because of one simple
complaint he's not allowed to yeah he's
allowed to ban a whole group of people
who's just sick of tailoring to vegan
people who want to have all this stuff
and get angry about me listen listen
wait a second he he got a two uh he got
a two-star review when he was on a Great
British menu right he ripped off his mic
smashed up the studio and said that he
wanted to kill the guy for giving him a
two-star review of a fish dish that he
made he didn't ban all Fish Eaters took
from his records
Joey listen we're gonna get it personal
you were a gang member so don't take the
high moral regret of it I'm smashing
something I'm completely honest about it
there's been documentaries I don't take
the high moral ground about it losing
your temper literally in the game I was
10 years ago 10 years sober now you're
going to use it to say if you're going
to get personal with it but anyways I
don't walk around with uh dead baby pigs
facing them like that like does that
look like somebody else like you know
they're horrible have you seen footage
from inside a gas station I recently
exposed one in the UK yeah
in Perth there's a gas chamber called
Lily Valley pork right and this guy
observes pork at his restaurant and why
would you be more upset that of a little
complaint as a chef then pigs being
murdered okay let me ask you the
question that I asked a vegan activist
the other day which is that given that
uh 80 or 90 of the world's almonds come
from California where they're a maid in
The involving the demolition of billions
of bees who get murdered how do you feel
about them don't get murdered that's
completely false and I don't know how
many billions how many billions die in
in the pollination I've got the 2022
data right on here they die mostly from
parasites and pests 66 die of uh varroa
mites or other pests and parasites in
the main disease in the making excuse me
almonds and avocados oh they do they do
the dangerous it's this year do you know
where I read serious dates from U.S
department of Agriculture do you know
where I read this I read it in the
guardian the vegan Bible even the
guardian excuse me admitted that you
vegans avocados 6.7 this is not don't
care about the little guys billions of
beans and you don't care where do those
bees come from huh where are those in
America they come from all over the
country the commercial honey industry
that's true and a lot of them what a big
vegan's boycott gone the commercial
honey industry why don't you boil your
armors and avocados because I don't see
a reason to most of the bees are dying
from mites do you see people okay all
right listen so you don't care about
them 36 die from pesticides so it's not
really a rights violation not murdering
here's my point
a big pig makes you cry a little bit you
don't you don't care no listen you don't
care about it there's no reason to be
upset sometimes pollination sometimes
they die from Millions why aren't you
angry at the mic hang on Joey over each
other sometimes 50 billion bees die in
six months to give you vegan literally
that's not true agriculture that is not
very true
read the guardian I read it in an
article let me an anecdote so it must be
true how long have you been a vegan uh
ten years right do you actually because
you seem quite agitated to me like you
want a bit about nonsense about bees
being murdered when they die from they
are murdered they're murdered
Behavior but you think in a way you
represent what I feel about things that
you're all quite hungry are you Against
Animal Cruelty peers yes then why do you
support animal cruelty when you support
them you don't I've defended the bees
for years
they're not murdered billions of bees
are murdered
honey where they're hired from John let
me let me bring in John here uh John
look here's my point about the vegans
there's a lot of hypocrisy as there is
with all these debates right which is
that if you want to eat almonds and
avocados as a vegan you feel virtuous
you think you're saving the planet as
well actually neither of those things
are true billions of bees get killed to
make almonds and avocados people can go
read the the proper reports about this
yeah and also they fly the men around
the world or they Chuck them around the
world and they call that it's terrible
for the for the Planet truck animal
products around the world do you believe
genre there's a kind of basic hypocrisy
here with the vegans
look I I think peers what I've noticed
is that there's a strange correlation
that they have between
um eating meat and death and murder
which they'd like to keep promoting that
murder aside I think if they look at the
definition of murder you know this is
human versus human and that is it you
know look I'm 100 Against Animal Cruelty
and for him to bring up the Great
British menu well it just shows his
mentality you know good lad
congratulations well done it's not what
we're about I think each should be to
their own and you should just enjoy your
life you know if they're gonna argue
peers
killing animals look at this Joey it's
supposed to take the murdered people
yeah
it wasn't just you can't handle a simple
complaint from and this woman she's a
very nice back to this young woman it's
very nice very kind very polite and you
can't handle a symptom Joey let me ask
you a question celebrity
everyone watching this either on the
show tonight or on YouTube later go and
Google bees US Departments
right here avocados and you'll see the
truth and the truth even the guardian
where they all are compelled to eat
lentils every day when they wear their
sandals to work this is a gas chamber
piece this is how pigs are killed and
explored in the UK this is my
investigation thank you a question why
don't you play me why don't you play me
the sound of billions of bees being
murdered
right look at them face them what do you
think bees do what do you think bees do
when you murder them they get killed by
mice this is gas chamber look at it I
don't know they didn't want to look at
it they get salted your account cowardly
I know that animals get slaughtered so
that I can eat animals stuck this camera
in this gas chamber in the UK at
Pilgrim's Pride and they scream for
their lives and every single animal
welfare uh here's my problem here's my
problem and you eat bacon and you
promote it I love bacon you promote it I
love bacon you say you're against that I
love sausages I love it all I love
eating meat you love animal cruelty yeah
I'm prepared to admit I love eating meat
you're not prepared to denounce avocado
and almonds because you're making
because they actually lead to
pollination
final word to John John is there
anything that will beside your mind to
let vegans in
there's obviously he'd be a fantastic
guest in your restaurant
discrimination isn't it thank you peers
absolutely childish childish behavior
discriminating against the whole group
of people because of one little silly
complaint go ahead
last time I laughed when I heard you say
that all bees are slaughtered because of
avocados it's an absolute object it's an
absolute
facts they care about your feelings yeah
final word is how many vegans does it
take to change a light bulb
go on
none
or wait for the punchline what's the
punchline
go have a crime to stay in the dark
go have a question the other one I like
is how do you know when someone's vegan
don't worry gas chamber footage don't
worry you can they'll soon tell you and
play uh pictures and stuff of people
murdered well they won't play you it's
bees uh Joey great to see you John thank
you for joining me for birth